can you try to make sense of this
situation that's going on right now dr.
Paul well I do by looking at it and it's
an unworkable situation you finally get
to the point where it doesn't work they
hang on to every word the Federal
Reserve Board Chairman says and
sometimes one word can make a difference
of billions and billions of dollars and
and we have an economic system that's
chaotic and then within we end up with a
president that does change his mind once
in a while you know and it's just how
they hang too much on words that don't
mean anything because they're talking
about problems they don't fully
understand from my viewpoint and they
don't have any solutions because they
always talk about more government
solutions and they're not willing to
look at our viewpoint from the
libertarian viewpoint maybe they've made
a lot of mistakes and maybe they should
talk about eliminating the mistakes
rather than just adding on to it so I'm
not surprised about it but it is still
pretty annoying so but it's gonna
continue for a while because nobody's
gonna nobody's going to come up with an
answer ever is gonna agree with with
Trump's dissertation on this you know he
wants to stir up the animosity to the
American people but the American people
ask for this too because i trouble adds
up the dollars that we spend over there
that they didn't spend back here but you
always have to have a balance of
payments and we send all that money over
that we have printed a lot of consumers
have been very happy it has served us
well and and then the Chinese govern
ants our deficit so this game has been
going on but today it lists everything
that we ever bought from China is
practically China stole that money from
us and we're going to get it back and
this tariff thing is is so so confident
not controversial but it still advise is
that you put on tariffs to punish China
in a few people now are starting to
recognize Oh a tariff is paid by the
people who put it on so the American
taxpayers pay for those tariffs so we've
had all this advantages of printing
money but they don't talk about the
problem because if you don't follow
Trump's argument you have to say oh
we're living beyond our means oh we have
a deficit oh we have a Federal Reserve
the reserve bank in the world that
it's a lot of money and we're were the
cause of all this imbalance but I think
the discrepancy in wealth in this
country is the same thing it's it's
caused by the monetary system and that I
think is a serious problem and given
giving a lot of ammunition to the
Socialists which I see capitalism
doesn't work so therefore we have to be
socialists and of course as far as I'm
concerned going in the wrong direction
you